there are lots of really serious policy
analyses to be done and that we
regularly do about the current
administration the current Republicans
at the House Senate Donald Trump but
sometimes it's less about policy and
more about just the patently vile and
gross nature of Donald Trump as an
individual and nothing is more
emblematic of that than this picture of
Donald Trump pumping his fists and
excitement as he was entering the 9/11
Memorial in Pennsylvania and as you know
yesterday was the 17th anniversary of
the 9/11 terrorist attacks we focused on
the cost of post 9/11 wars in our
coverage yesterday and one of the things
Donald Trump did was to go to
Pennsylvania to the memorial for the
victims of flight 93 which crashed there
and on the way in Trump looked like a
little kid waiting to get on the newest
ride at Disney World not like an adult
who understands the somber and sad
circumstances and meaning of that
memorial and people are going to write
in and they'll say David you know I
heard that Trump was actually pumping
his fists because he was gonna see a kid
with cancer who was meeting him at that
thing Trump was seen with his powerful
and violent thumbs up all over 911
related stuff and this has been a trend
with Trump and it's not about being fake
outraged or being offended or anything
of the sort
Trump's policy ideas and his actions are
what make him fundamentally unqualified
to be President of the United States
you don't need superficial insensitivity
which he has plenty of to make the case
that Trump shouldn't be the president
this is about more broadly understanding
that we have an underdeveloped child
running the country and Trump's tweet on
9/11 sort of not insensitive but totally
dumb and shows his lack of awareness of
the gravity of what we're talking about
when we talk about the 9/11 anniversary
Donald Trump tweeting 17 years since
September 11th exclamation point and
it's not just now that Trump is off the
charts
9/11 when 9/11 first happened Trump
called in - I think it was in 2008 and
his remark was that because the Twin
Towers had fallen because of a terrorist
attack mind you his building was now the
tallest in lower Manhattan this is a
person with a deficient or faulty
character it's like a broken personality
and it's a real embarrassment for the
entire country and for everybody who's
not embarrassed by Trump you're a part
of that embarrassment you're a part of
the problem and if you're not able to
see this behavior and realize that it is
the behavior of a damaged dangerous
person who needs to be removed from
office right away before he does even
more damage you are part of the problem
and I know people are gonna get mad why
because they get mad no matter what I
say I know that if you're running for
office candidates should use inclusive
language and that's where maybe Hillary
Clinton was wrong to use the term
deplorable 'he's about Trump supporters
she wasn't wrong about the term it was
probably just bad strategy to use that
term it wasn't a good strategic term to
use I'm not running for anything there's
no other candidate I'm trying to get you
to vote for right now if you don't see
what's going on you were prior to part
of the problem and what we need to do
and by we I mean not only progressives
but I also mean right-wingers who
understand the problem we need to do
what we can to remove the guy from
office as soon as possible and by that I
mean like yesterday and if you think
that individually fist-pumping as you
enter a 9/11 Memorial isn't notable in
any way just remember what the right did
when Barack Obama was President of the
United States and he wore a tan suit or
chose the wrong type of mustard okay if
that was disrespectful or elitist and
worthy of discussion on Fox News and by
Rush Limbaugh and Hannity and all of
those people then what is this what is
this answer that question for me I am
begging you